as I interviewed you over the years of
course I asked you about the virgin
thing because it was a huge part of your
storyline on the shows and you've kind
of said different things about why you
had made that choice to be a virgin does
the book get into that more like how
much of it was those Christian values
that you've grown up with I think now
that I'm like taking a step back I was
so insecure because I was still
questioning like what like why is this
hard for me to put into words like why
can't I just say it's because I'm a
Christian because I believe you should
wait till marriage it's like because
that's not a hundred percent accurate
that's not a hundred percent reason sole
reason why I'm why I am urging I just I
just feel like it's an important it's an
important value of mine that I hold
close but there are so many things that
go into it and I do get into it in the
book between my parents divorce in
college sort of messing me up between
getting bullied in grade school and in
high school and literally googling am i
gay how do I know if I'm gay why don't I
want to have sex and then internalizing
it all and sort of just moving forward
with football I think it's a mixture of
all those now that I can look back and
be like that's what made me me I mean
there there is no one thing that's on
your Road that changes your life there's
very rarely that one instinct and that's
the case with this virginity it's not
just one thing I wish I could say it was
all God because I know that's you know
what he wants for us but it's not it's
that that's not the case
well whew to open up and share that you
questioned your sexuality from being
bullied that you googled am i gay
those are huge things to share with
people what conclusions did you
ultimately draw about yourself as you
explored and questioned all that well
I'll consider I've never acted on
anything I think that there was a quote
there was questions there and I like I
said I either internalized it or move
forward with football and The Bachelor
for me going on the Bachelorette was a
way for me not to be able to run from a
relationship not to be scared and to
open up and I
that I think to you before interviews
I'm so grateful that for the franchise
for helping me grow but they continue to
allow me to have these moments of
self-reflection to realize hey maybe
this is why I am the way I am and I
think that that's what's been so cool
and what was so therapeutic about
writing this book in the first place is
it was challenging at times to really
push myself and really ask myself some
of the difficult and hard questions to
really figure out who I am as a person
so what did the shows teach you about
your sexuality I mean obviously then I'm
straight and that I'm very very
attracted to kasi and women but it would
have been okay if I was the other way
too I think that was I think that's like
the biggest message that I have for
people is I was so I was stuck in a
hyper masculine culture with the ball
growing up in a conservative faith-based
family and walking with God and that
saying hey I can't walk with God and be
gay and that's not true and saying hey I
can't play football be gay and that's
not true but I lived within those boxes
and within those walls and what doesn't
within those areas because that's what I
was told so I think that was like moreso
the struggle for me was like you know
how do I talk about this with anybody
and I didn't and that's where I think it
sort of was frustrating because I didn't
have a friend to talk to I didn't want
to talk to my parents about it I mean I
remember I put in the book there was a
rumor going around my high school that I
was gay because I broke up of one of my
girlfriends at the time and my mom it
even got to my mom where my mom was was
you know pulled me aside and said you
know what you'd still love you if you're
gay I was like well I appreciate that
but like I gotta figure this out there's
a little awkward it's interesting for
you to say that the show has really kind
of confirmed your sexuality for you
because that's a huge chunk of time for
you to be questioning all that but like
in high school and in your 20s cuz how
when you went on the shows 25 26 yeah I
was 25 when I first went on and I think
this show I mean obviously not only
confirm that for me but it helped me
confront that that feeling because you
know I mean you guys probably didn't pay
attention to it as much as I did by even
when I
was announced or even when I people said
I was a virgin there was there was
headlines saying I was gay saying I was
closeted saying that I'm doing this for
attention that I'm really like even now
I still battle gay rumors when I'm with
Cassie but that's how it was for me as a
young young kid in grade school in high
school and I can deal with them now and
I can look at him and be like okay like
take your shots and I understand because
people sometimes when they don't
understand they have to get from point A
to point B somehow and that's a line
they draw and that's just what they do
to make sense of things in their mind
but why if anybody takes anything from
this or is going through this I help one
young man or one young woman go through
something that they're struggling what
to let them know that they're not
allowed alone then I consider the book a
huge success
[Music]